[Musik]
guten abend und willkommen zu einem
kurzen nachrichten überblick in der
halbzeitpause
es ist ein tag des gedenkens heute vor
genau 25 jahren begann das schlimmste
verbrechen auf europäischem boden nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg der völkermord von
srebrenica der bosnienkrieg in ex
jugoslawien war fast vorbei als bosnisch
serbische milizen innerhalb weniger tage
mehr als 8000 muslime töteten
vorwiegend jungen und männer britta
hilpert es ist ein meer von stählen hier
liegen über 8000 tote über 8000
ermordete bosniaken und jedes jahr
kommen weitere stelen dazu 25 jahre nach
dem völkermord von srebrenica werden
neun erst kürzlich identifizierte zu
grabe getragen
du gehst mir den trauer und
erleichterung empfindet hassiba musik
ihr mann findet erst heute seine letzte
ruhestätte muse am 11 juli 95 nehmen
bosnisch serbische einheiten unter ratko
mladic die un-schutzzone srebrenica 1600
ihr der niederländischen blauhelme
doch dort finden sie keinen schutz im
laden einheiten führen die männer ab
erschießen sie und verscharren sie in
massengräbern
das gedenken war corona bedingt
eingeschränkt viele nationen schicken
videobotschaften in denen sie sich zu
ihrer verantwortung bekennen
doch es fehlten serbische vertreter sie
leugnen bis heute den völkermord
erinnern an das leid und den schmerz ist
ein zentraler baustein für versöhnung
genauso gehört die strafrechtliche
aufarbeitung der geschehnisse dazu noch
nicht alle toten von srebrenica sind
würdig begraben nicht alle
kriegsverbrecher verurteilt in bosnien
herzegowina ist srebrenica keine
vergangenheit sondern die gegenwart
in der serbischen hauptstadt belgrad ist
es in der nacht wieder zu gewaltsamen
protesten gekommen
dabei stimmten nationalistische
demonstranten das parlamentsgebäude
ihre wut richtet sich gegen präsident
vucic er möchte wieder gespräche mit dem
kosovo aufnehmen
für hardliner ist das kosovo eine
abtrünnige provinz serbiens
zuvor hatten tausende gegen die korona
beschränkungen der regierung
demonstriert nach deutschland
wirtschaftsminister altmaier hält eine
abschaffung der masken pflicht für viel
zu früh darüber könnten mediziner und
politiker nachdenken wenn die zahl der
neuinfektionen dauerhaft zweistellig sei
sagte altmaier der frankfurter
allgemeinen einen rückgang auf unter 100
neuinfektionen pro tag es aber derzeit
nicht absehbar auch wenn die zahlen
weiter sinken
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 360 menschen neu mit
dem virus angesteckt gestern waren es
noch 380 nach new york dort ring der un
sicherheitsrat seit tagen darum eine
lösung zu finden damit die notleidende
bevölkerung in syrien weiter
internationale hilfslieferungen bekommt
es geht um das schicksal von millionen
syrien die bislang über zwei türkisch
syrische grenze übergänge mit
lebensmitteln medizin versorgt wurden
die frist für diese hilfslieferungen das
in der nacht ausgelaufen
auch ein deutsch tschechischer
kompromissvorschlag wurde von russland
und china abgelehnt johannes hano in new
york gibt es noch hoffnung dass die
hilfe weiter geht also dass sich die 15
länder im rat auf einen kompromiss
einigen
also deutschland und belgien hatten über
nacht einen neuen vorschlag gemacht der
vor seinen übergang für ein jahr und
einen weiteren für drei monate damit die
hilfsorganisation sich logistisch
umstellen können aber auch der wurde
jetzt wieder von russland und china
abgelehnt
jetzt liegt ein neuer vorschlag auf dem
tisch der sagt ein übergang für ein jahr
das entspricht eigentlich im kern der
russischen forderungen doch russland und
china haben da auch wieder jetzt zwei
neue anhänge formuliert die sie mit
abgestimmt haben wollen und die sehen
vor dass der un sicherheitsrat oder die
un mehr oder weniger zu dem schluss
kommen darüber abstimmen dass die
sanktionen der es gegen das assad-regime
urenkel ursächlich sind
für das leid der bevölkerung und das hat
selber in der lage ist dieses ganze zu
übernehmen die humanitäre kontrolle da
sehen die mehrheit im sicherheitsrat
sieht das völlig anders als hat sei
nicht in der lage
und zweitens würde das nur seinen
günstlingen zukommen lassen also da
treffen im moment welten aufeinander und
es ist noch völlig offen wie die heute
abgestimmt wird
dankeschön für diese einschätzung live
aus new york in gefahr dass die us
demokraten werfen präsident jump
amtsmissbrauch vor den jump hat seinem
langjährigen berater roger stone eine
dreijährige haftstrafe erlassen
sturm wäre im gefängnis einem
ernsthaften medizinischen risiko
ausgesetzt worden hieß es aus dem weißen
haus der jump vertraute war im zuge der
russland affäre verurteilt worden wegen
falschaussagen und beeinflussung von
zeugen er hätte am dienstag ins
gefängnis gehen müssen
die behörden auf lampedusa schlagen
alarm und fordern von der italienischen
regierung den notstand auszurufen der
grund in den letzten tagen kamen mehrere
boote mit hunderten flüchtlingen im
hafen der insel an
sie wurden in quarantäne zentren
untergebracht die völlig überfüllt sind
die situation sei untragbar so die
regionalregierung seit einigen wochen
wagen wieder mehr flüchtlinge den
gefährlichen weg über das mittelmeer in
düsseldorf gab es wieder eine aktion
gegen rassismus und fremdenfeindlichkeit
unter einhaltung der abstandsregeln
versammelten sich mehrere hundert
menschen vor dem landtag
überwiegend schwarz gekleidet erinnerten
sie an den tod von george freut der
46-jährige starb ende mai in den usa bei
einer gewaltsamen festnahme der polizei
nur noch zum wetter das bringt am
sonntag noch ein bisschen regen an den
alpen und im norden ansonsten ist es
trocken und sonnig katja hat gleich die
details danke für ihr interesse haben
sie noch einen spannenden abend und bis
morgen wenn sie möglich auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren auch
in dieser nacht können sie wieder den
kometen weiß und nachtleuchtende wolken
beobachten wie unser zuschauer michael
landgrebe zeit treffend vor drei tagen
in lindau am bodensee besonders gut
klappt das zwischen dem oberrhein und
rüben an den alpen und an der nordsee
fällt etwas regen bei 13 bis 6 grad
morgen ist es meist sonnig und trocken
und einzig in norddeutschland können
kleine regenschauer auftreten und die
temperaturen steigen auf 18 bis 26 grad
die neue woche startet sommerlich und
geht dann wechselhafter weiter schönen
sonntag